Hello and welcome to today's rather impromptu episode
of Rawkode Live. Today, we're gonna be taking
a look at Kubernetes services, breaking it down
and trying to understand how they work, how
to use them and anything else that pops
up. Today, I'm joined by Anna Ace and
Philip. Hello. How are you both?
Hello. Great.
Thank you. So,
at a moment Great to. Thanks for having
me. Yeah. No. My my pleasure, honestly.
Let's just quickly
I'll have you both do a quick introduction,
and then we'll talk about why we're here,
what we wanna cover, and then we'll just
get straight into it and see what happens.
So, Yves, would you like to go first?
Awesome.
Yeah. Sure.
So I guess,
also kind of the story of how it
came to this episode
in some way.
I've just recently transitioned into DevOps.
I've worked for the past years in the
blockchain industry,
mainly doing community management and developer relations,
and then found out about Codefresh,
which is a CICD platform,
and joined Codefresh mid of October.
And since then, I've embarked on this learning
journey across DevOps and
specifically learning everything that I can about Kubernetes.
So
I've made it my mission, so to say,
to put everything that I'm learning live
on a public Notion page where you can
read my notes and
everything that I come across and any resources
that I found particular useful.
So
I've just started, end of last year, a
challenge called one hundred days of Kubernetes, where
I aim to learn every day something new
about Kubernetes. And I've realized in the past
days,
so to say, that I don't quite understand
enough about services and specifically ports
within Kubernetes resources.
And so that's what this
episode is going to be more about.
Yeah. Awesome. Thank you. Philip?
Yeah. So I'm Philip.
I ended up on this livestream mostly because
I saw a tweet and offered to answer
some questions.
I've been in
cloud and containers and Kubernetes for quite a
long time. It's more like ten years than
one hundred days. I started a PaaS company
in 02/2009
and I'm currently spending my days working on
an open source Terraform framework
that helps people do GitOps with Terraform for
Kubernetes, basically.
And,
yeah, well, I just am excited to see
what the questions are gonna be and if
we can figure it out together.
Fingers crossed. I'm I'm I'm sure between us
we'll we'll get through this for sure.
Alright. Yes. We'll I'm I'm pretty sure. Yeah.
I mean, I'm confident. I mean,
know it's one of those things. The more
you use Kubernetes, I think the more things
you learn that you just don't understand were
there. So but Yeah. But That comes more
natural.
Exactly.
Alright. So why don't we start with
was there any YAML and specifically that you
were working with, Anais, that you would like
us to use and go through to try
and break down? Or do you want me
just to throw something together really quickly and
we can talk about the different components as
we kind of go?
Yeah. So I was just using, like, a
really basic
React application and kind of deploying
the container on my cluster and getting up
and running through a deployment,
and then started from there to integrate, like,
services with it on the cluster. So it's
really basic YAML.
The main problem was basically that there's there
are lots of resources,
but there are little resources that go in
detail of, like, the different components that make
up that YAML file.
So, yeah, feel free to throw something together.
That might be interesting.
Hey. Well, yeah. Let's see if I can
remember how to YAML. But
what I'll do is
throw together
two NGINX services.
So we'll call this NGINX one and I
know it's state partially difficult to read, but
hopefully the code here should be better.
So we have a deployment, we'll call this
NGINX one
and we'll deploy
NGINX.
I'll just let this yell at me, and
nginx runs on port 80. This is what
I would just call a really standard
deployment.
And we'll have two. So let's do, oh,
too much.
And what we wanna do is, I'm assuming
when you were working through the YAML that
you were working with us, want two services
or two deployments or pods to be able
to communicate with each other over the Kubernetes
control plane.
Yeah. Yeah. That as well. And
also, I mean, starting, like, really simple,
just how do you access
how would you access starting from, like, the
beginning? How would you create a note port
and access
your application,
your running application?
It's like one step back. Yeah. I don't
think that's actually a step back.
I would probably start from inside out.
Right? So,
I think it's better to first understand what
a pod does and how the communication
between multiple containers inside a pod would work.
And then we can go how can two
pods talk to each other. And then we
can go to the point of
how
do we deploy a bunch of pods from
a deployment. Right? Because that's again, it's another
abstraction layer on top already.
So I don't know how how
I don't know how to start this. Should
we just, like, look at the pod for
a starting point?
There
is quite a lot on what you mentioned
there. So
let's let's
So yeah, what you said there is we
could talk about the networking model with multiple
containers in the single pod without ever reaching
the network stack across the services first,
That's your suggestion, okay.
So let's
modify our first pods back then, I'll add
a second container, we'll deploy it to the
cluster and then
we can talk about what is actually here.
So we'll call this NGINX one dot two
and NGINX one dot one
and that won't actually work, will it? Because
the ports
will try to bind on the same interface.
So let's deploy something else.
What's that? In this case?
Yes, please. In this case, how do you
know that the container port is 80? Is
it is it by default?
I'm just yeah, I'm just really familiar with
NGINX and I know that it runs on
port 80 as does HTTPD,
know, this is like the the standard non
TLS HTTP
port
and
maybe Philip can explain this slightly better than
I can now. So if you run multiple
containers in a single pod, they share the
same namespace of networking space, which means that
we cannot have two engine access running on
port I believe, and we can confirm that
just now actually, but if I try to
deploy this, it will fail. Is that right,
Philip?
Yes. That's pretty right. So I think basically
the way I look at this, and I'm
no expert in networking at all, I just
help myself by, you know, having like a
bridge to understand this. Basically, I'm looking at
a port as a computer.
Right? It has one network interface, has one
IP address, and so it shares
the port namespace. Right? So any port inside
this one computer can only be used once.
Of course, that isn't true because you can
have virtual interfaces.
And then each virtual interface has its own
set of ports. Right? But for this specific
example, it's just the port has
one of those pod IPs.
Right?
And so any container you start inside shares
the number of available ports. So you cannot
use them twice.
And if they want to talk to each
other within
that that port,
they can talk to each other. So one
container talking to another container inside the same
port, they can talk to each other localhost
and that port that you are listening on.
So if you start nginx twice, you would
have to have one of them listen on
a different
port.
Exactly. And we've just confirmed that. We can
actually see here that our NGINX two pod
is relatively happy here, but our NGINX one
pod does keep adder in and that's because
it cannot rebind that port number.
So that means we have to,
if we wanted to show how the networking
works within a single pod, we need to
run something else that doesn't listen on port
80.
Any quick suggestions of an image that's
I can throw in here?
I'm not super familiar with the NGINX image,
but it probably has an environment variable that
you can tell it to use different part
now.
Probably. I just don't know what it is.
Well, so yeah. We would have to check
out with the images documentation.
I I just run MariaDB 10. I think
that's the right tag.
Yeah. It runs on it's the MySQL port,
which is gonna be,
I can't even remember, but it's not port
80. So
let's put this in and we run our
watch again. That should get
healthy.
That's the old one that I've heard so
I'm not worried about that. And the second
one just hasn't come up yet, so we'll
give that a moment.
Yeah. We had a
no, I've broken that one too. Oh yeah,
MySQL.
I I'm feeling miserably.
So we had some good comments as well
there at the same time. Let me see.
So Costa said, TCO sector support, you are
correct.
And also use Redis. Yeah. That may have
been easier. The reason the MariaDB
slash MySQL one just failed there is that
it actually can't run without some environment variables,
so that was a very terrible choice in
the image by myself.
Does Redis need environment Yeah, also like a
bit of an anti pattern, right? You shouldn't
run your NGINX and your database in the
same pot. That's a bit of a Cut
me some slack, fella. This is a demo.
This isn't this isn't I'm not shipping it
to production, I promise.
But we should probably mention this to the
viewers so they don't, you know, tune out
because we're complete morons. Oh yeah, someone's just
tuned in right there and went, they're doing
what? No. It's closed. So,
yeah, I wouldn't recommend that part and you're
correct.
Yeah, Redis I think is happy with any
environment variable. So you can see now that
this has worked. So let's talk about what
actually happened there.
If we describe pod one seven which is
our new one with Redis,
We can see that we have two containers
here running on a single pod.
And
what happens there is that they share the
same networking space, they share the same port
allocations, they can communicate over local host.
Sorry. Anything we need to be able to
add there. Does that even make sense to
everyone what I've just said?
Yes. Okay. I think it makes sense. Yeah.
It does make sense.
If engine x in this case, right, was
a web application we had written and not
like this web server only,
we could now talk to our Redis with
local host and whatever the Redis port is.
Yeah. But if you wanted this process in
if the NGINX process was not NGINX but
our own web application,
it can now talk to Redis by connecting
to local host and the Redis port.
Yeah.
And the benefits of that are that it
doesn't go over your traditional kernel TCP network
in the stack. Right? It's it's typically faster.
There's no security
risks, at least less security risks.
Is that a that a fair Yeah. Well,
if you this,
you're basically talking local host. Right? Those two
processes will end up on the same node.
So it's the same local host connection that
you would have on
if you were to do this on your
single computer.
If you had put those two
containers into different pods, they may end up
being scheduled to different nodes.
And then you would actually have increased latency
as a first step because you might actually
end up talking through a real network on
different machines And that adds
latency, right? So for web applications, there sometimes
is a use case where you would do
something like this because
you want your cache to be very, very
fast, right? And you put them right next
to the actual process that uses the cache.
Can, in certain applications, have benefits.
It's kind of hard say with this And
in this example, let's say they would be
in different both containers would be in different
pods, but they would be running in the
same node? For instance, if I have only
one node and I can be certain about
that, they would not be able to communicate
through localhost, or they would be?
They would not.
They would not be. If they are in
different pods, each pod has its own IP
And if you want to Okay. Between
pods Then they would have to know them.
Have to go to the network for communication.
Okay.
Okay. So that covers
networking
within a pod using local hosts. You know,
the only thing you really need to be
aware of is port collisions. If you navigate
that, there are use cases for using multiple
containers in the same port. This in pods,
this is generally what we call the sidecar
pattern in Kubernetes land where we want to
be able to add extra functionality to our
applications without modifying our own
code kind of. Yeah.
Alright, so let's get back to then, I
know you see the original question was
networking across
across pods
and namespaces and all of our Kubernetes clusters
and using services. Now there's three different types
of services if I remember correctly.
Do we wanna discuss what each of those
are and the use cases for each?
I think one thing I guess point out
before we go there is
Yeah. The service doesn't actually do the networking.
Right? Any port can talk to any other
port.
The difficulty is just you don't know its
IP address.
Services So you wouldn't hard code it. Service
discovery. They help you how to
find out who to talk to.
Right? Yeah. That is correct. The service concept
or primitive within Kubernetes, right? I mean, service
discovery, which is, you know, a pretty much
a solved problem when you adopt Kubernetes and
load balancing across the pods within that service.
Right. On what service type you choose, then
you also would get, for example, load balancing
because the service has its service IP address.
It announces the service IP address in DNS.
And so when you try to talk to
this service, you can talk to a DNS
name. It resolves to the service's IP address.
And the service has endpoints
which are all the pods that it can
find via its selector labels. And this is
how it can end up talking to these
various pods.
Okay.
So this is like a big That was
a nice explanation.
To make this more understandable for everybody.
I think it would be useful, like, for
this demonstration
to focus on the difference between cluster IP
and node port,
unless we want to, I mean.
No. No. That makes sense. So To what
you might understand.
Cluster IP is is the default service type.
So we'll get one of those running.
And node port is got some very specific
use cases that, okay, I guess it's actually
the four service tip. The third one would
be a load balancer type, which is only
supported in some environments and the fourth one
would be a headless service, which actually
handles traffic in a slightly unique way. But
we're gonna disregard those and focus on cluster
IP and node port and try and break
that down for you. So
let's expose.
Oh, there's also
there's also there's no port and host port
if you wanna make it really complicated. And
then there is also
I forgot the name, but there's a service
type which does nothing but add an entry
to the DNS,
to the internal Kubernetes DNS.
I think it's called external DNS or something
like
external name Yeah.
It's a service type external or something, external
DNS, something like this, or external name.
Don't know how to up. Yeah. I don't
think it's oh,
the semantics aren't important, but you're right. Yeah.
There is the ability to bring an external
services and expose them as a Kubernetes service.
Okay. So
let's make a
service available for our first
deployment here, which has this label.
Can the name be anything? Like in this
case, when you named a service?
It could be anything that is a DNS
compatible
name.
And so you can't
use dots, but you can use you know,
alphanumeric
and dashes.
And it doesn't have to be connect in
this case with the deployment. It just So
it's connected to something called a selector, which
is based on the labels.
So you can see here what I'm telling
that, I mean services are relatively
simple as the definition.
All we're saying here is we wanna make
something available with this name NGINX one and
it's gonna find any target which has a
label called app with the value NGINX one.
And
we could Yeah. So I think the question,
you're free to name the service anything you
like as long as it is
according to the Kubernetes naming convention. Right?
But it probably makes sense to call it
something that's related to your deployment so you
keep track of which two things belong together.
You know, if your deployment is called doc
and the service is called cat,
that, you know, may not be the best
idea.
Exactly. Yeah. I think, you know, it's always
valuable to remember that, well, Kubernetes is a
computer and we'll do whatever is told that
humans are usually working with this and we
want to make it as simple as possible.
Well, standard naming conventions do make a lot
of sense but I'm gonna go against that
now because I've already renamed it to anise
one, so let's go with that.
Alright,
now we can get away with very little
bit of config here and rely a lot
on the defaults, so I'm just gonna apply
this, we'll see what we get and we'll
try and
understand what's actually happened here. So I've not
set a service type in the spec, All
I've done is configure the selector and tell
it the port that we want the service
to be available on. This is probably So
On you go. Yeah.
No. I wanted to drill more on the
container port versus port
On how
is that the port that's the service and
then the service forwards that to the container
port and the container
port could be something different or do they
have to like, what is the relation between
those two ports or they don't have any
relation? Yeah. Yeah. So the port will be
the port number that the service IP is
available on. You can then have that point
to a different port within the container if
you need. So like if you have an
application that listens on a random port and
you want to expose over a standard port,
then you can configure that correctly and then
node port brings in another
variable to the mix as well that we
cover when we do other node ports.
I think that's right.
Let's apply.
So now if we run
kubectl get services,
you'll see here we have the annex one
service that we created
and then now gets a cluster IP because
that's the default service type. And we can
ignore external IP for now and it's exposed
on the port that we told it to
be available on. It just so happens to
be the same port that NGINX is listening
on, but that is
most irrelevant right now.
Another really viable command when working with services
Kubernetes is to describe it and what you're
looking for here every time is this endpoints
and more often not if your service isn't
working within the cluster is because it has
no endpoints and the number one reason at
least in my experience here is if there
are no endpoints on the service, you have
your selector wrong.
Meaning I cannot fetch any pods with that
selector.
A good way to confirm that that also
works is to use a label selector when
you do get pods.
So we can run this command here and
if that returns pods, then your endpoint is
configured correctly.
The endpoint in this case is the endpoint
of the of the container like that refers
to to the pod
that the containers run-in or?
So when we apply the service to the
cluster, the cluster will grab that selector. It
will look up all of the pods. And
if they're ready and available, they will be
added to the endpoints list, which just means
that they're available to handle any request to
that service IP address.
By default, it will just add all of
them, but you have the readiness check to
determine if it's actually ready. Right? So if
you configure a readiness check-in your port,
this is how you can control
at what point your application is ready to
be added as an endpoint.
Or because the readiness readiness check will run
continuously
along the lifetime of the pod,
it would also remove it from the endpoints
if at some point in the future your
readiness check turns false again.
A by default. The readiness check runs automatically,
or that's something that will also be defined
in the YAML in that case? No. In
the pod, you have the ability to configure
two health checks,
the readiness check and the liveness probe.
And the readiness one determines if it's inside
the
endpoints,
if it's included in load balancing, basically.
And the other one determines if it's being
it's going to be restarted
according to whatever rules you put in there.
And in that case, like, if I don't
define the values, they are, by default, defined
to certain numbers, to certain values? Or No.
If you don't define it, then it's just
included in the endpoints immediately as soon as
Kubernetes has started the container.
And then it doesn't basically
determine if the process inside the container
has had time to come up. For example,
Java applications can take
quite a bit of time to boot up
in a lot of cases. Right? Yeah, couple
of weeks. So you might, may actually end
up sending traffic to this process already before
the process is ready to answer.
Yeah.
Yeah,
maybe it makes sense to go into liveness
and readiness
problem, maybe we can do that after a
little bit of the service stuff unless
you wanna dive into it then let let
me know.
Yeah,
said there is, you know, a % correct.
Like if these exist, you can define when
your application is actually handling traffic correctly or
is ready to handle traffic and the services
can add and remove them as needed to
make sure that you're not delivering,
you know broken NGINX's to your customers and
such.
Yeah, great information.
Okay. So
we have
two deployments, some pods, and a service that
allows us to now communicate. So I guess,
what do you think we should cover next?
Will we talk about
the DNS conventions for service discovery?
Yeah. One thing about the selector, we mentioned
that you have to set the selector, and
if you don't get it right, then you
usually end up having no endpoints and it
doesn't work.
Should we mention how you get it right?
What
labels you actually have to set where in
order for the selector to find your pods?
Yes, it's more extensive. I
found this super confusing because there's metadata labels
everywhere.
And I was like, do I put the
metadata labels in the deployment
or do they have to be under deployment
spec templates spec metadata labels? That's one of
my biggest frustrations
with
the
the selectors on a deployment is that there's
some replication
and I don't understand why it's
maybe not automated.
But yeah, you wanna break that down then
Philip?
No, was a question.
I'm not claiming I know everything.
Alright. So hold on. Let me get a
comment on. So Costa has said, yeah, we
should have a whole episode on live this
already readiness approach. I I think you're right.
There is a lot there. So maybe that's
something that I'll get scheduled soon. Alright, Very
cool.
Yeah, when you define a deployment,
so that, and much the same way that
a service works out which pods or endpoints
to load balance traffic over, a deployment has
to understand, I don't want to go too
deep in this because it's a bit of
a segue, the deployment has to work out
which replica sets are under its control, and
then the replica sets have to work out
which pods are under its control, and this
is labels all the way down.
So what we have here in the deployment
selector is say, all of replicate sets which
have a label of app and the value
of NGINX are under our control.
And then we have a template on the
pod spec which also adds labels of app
and NGINX to each of the pods.
And it's just like labels and all of
these different resources that grip them all together
in something like homogenous fashion
to
be
queried against the control plane.
If I got anything wrong there, feel free
to jump in and fix it.
And
in that case, like
I mean, as a complete newbie looking at
that, you would wonder at the beginning, why
can't you use the name for that as
a form of label? Do you have to
define the name? Or what happens if I
don't define
the name and a random name is set?
The labels have the benefit that you could
have multiple of those and you can query
for a combination also. Right? So there's some
rules you could say,
you can have like an app, engine x1,
like we have now, and you could have
another label for example, for an environment
for staging or prod. And then you could
make sure that the staging service
will only ever include
staging pods
by also querying for the environment.
Okay? Yeah. That would be one way. It's
there's also more advanced
use for this. But I think what's important
here is the
reason why we can set those templates here
inside the deployment spec is only because the
deployment is a higher level abstraction already. Yep.
And it has some
things it does to the resources that it
controls, replica sets and pods eventually.
Right? But if we were to use a
naked pod, which you almost never do unless
you want to understand this,
then you would have to set the labels
on the pod itself for the service to
find it.
Yeah. I mean, I try to avoid talking
about replica sets as much as possible.
And as people are learning Kubernetes, I don't
think there's a lot of value initially to
understand what their their role is. So maybe
that's a rather I actually have a
have a recruiting. If you if you apply
for a job and I end up recruiting
you, I'll ask about this quite a lot
because I think it's important to understand how
these things work together.
Because if it breaks and you have to
figure out why,
it's better to know.
Like my question is usually how does a
rolling update work? What happens inside the Kubernetes
control plane when you change the image tag
of your deployment? What does it do?
I do think that it's ported, but as
someone on their first month of Kubernetes, does
that make a lot of sense to break
it down? Oh, I don't know. Let's say
we're conflicted on that one.
Do you want to go next, This
was your question, and I don't want us
to get bogged down by details and random
things. I want to make No. I think
I think this is great.
I To be honest, there is also aspects
that I wouldn't, like, think about it in
a complex
manner, like replicasets.
For me, it's just like, oh, I want
to have two of the same thing, I
just use a replica set kind of style.
Right? So I guess it's something you also
discover through using it of, like, of the
specifics
of how they work and what might go
wrong or not.
But what would be cool to maybe go
into more detail
is actually a lot of, like, examples when
you look at basic deployment resources is they
they show multiple
port naming. They have, like, target port, port,
container
port,
and and then also when you introduce node
port, they have, like yeah, node port, they
have a node port. Right? And I think
that's then when I'm not too sure if
people,
like, also who have used it who have
been using it over time know the exact
connection or it's just something that people know
and they don't really write about.
So, that might be interesting to go into
more detail.
Okay. Service has I think services are a
little bit overloaded. Right? They have multiple use
cases. We already talked about the cluster IP
ones, which gives you another IP address inside
your cluster, basically, you can talk to.
A way to find this IP address via
DNS.
And then also the load balancing, whenever you
talk to this cluster IP address,
it will forward the traffic to one of
the ports that's behind it via this endpoint
mechanic that we just discussed. Right? But other
deployment types sorry, service types may actually do
something quite different. For example, the node port
you mentioned,
basically what node port does is instead of
reserving an IP address, I think it reserves
an IP address too, but that's out of
the point here,
is it also
sets up kube proxy to start listening
on the host, the worker,
on that specific port. So now you can
talk to the host's IP address.
And then
in case of the
I sometimes get this wrong and correct me.
Maybe Chad will correct me if I'm wrong.
But basically, there's a node port and host
port.
Node port
would set up Kube proxy on any node
in the cluster independently
if the port is running on that node
or not to listen on this port that
you specify
and set up IP tables magic
so that when you talk to any
node IP address and that port, the traffic
will end up at your port.
Okay?
And host port
does something similar except it only does this
on the node
that does actually
have
your pod running.
Does that make sense? It just saves you
a hop basically.
Let's
let's show this by example.
I think that's going to make sense. So
what I'm going to do is
firstly, we're going to update
this to be something more useful. So instead
of MariaDB, what we're actually going to use
is something from the open files project called
node info,
which I should call the right thing.
And because this is going to expose
as
we request the HTTP server on that container,
it's going to return information about the pod
to answer the request and that's going to
show us the load balancing. We'll expose that
as a cluster IP and I'm also gonna
expose it as a node port and then
we will take a look at how that
actually functions
and hopefully that answers a lot of the
questions that we have. So
we need to expose the port
and it runs on eighty eighty I believe,
so we should be okay running that side
by side with engine X.
That's already exposed as,
oh it's not, engine X is exposed as
annex one
and we'll also have Anais node info as
another service,
gonna have the same selector running on a
different
port.
And finally,
we'll do this again,
only this time, we'll add a type
of node port,
same selector
and we'll expose
the node info. And well, I'm not gonna
say any other fields right now, I'm just
gonna leave that as as we'll take a
look at what is created, but hopefully we'll
to explain it and show how it works.
I think what we'll probably have to look
at is when do you use one or
the other, right? They have different use cases
and I think that's what really matters in
the end.
I mean in my opinion, that's a really,
really simple question to answer. So I'm gonna
throw out my simple approach and let you
shoot that down.
But the only time you should ever, ever,
ever, ever, ever use a node port service
is if you want to expose something
outside of your cluster and it's not the
best way to do it. It's a kind
of a hacky quick way to do it
because you don't have any ingress controlled or
configured for your cluster.
So yeah, node port is only there if
you want a hacky quick expose us to
the wild or the Internet kind of thing.
Would you agree with that? Yeah, I would
agree with that. Yeah. No. I if you
want to expose something outside of the cluster,
the first thing you should look into is
ingress.
Right?
However, there may be some edge cases where
you have to go down to a lower
level and then those
node port host port services are
useful.
You'll if you ever end up setting up,
for example, NGINX Ingress, if you deploy your
own Ingress, then you will eventually have to
touch on this, right, because you need a
way to somehow get
the traffic to the NGINX Ingress controller in
the first place.
That's also where this host port, node port
difference comes into play.
So just clarifying in the in the ML
resources that you defined,
in those services where you didn't say node
port, it's by default cluster IP?
That is correct. If you emit it,
the default by
Kubernetes
control plane or the defaulters is to set
this to cluster IP.
Okay.
And the ports you just out of simplicity
reason named them
and the service the same as in the
deployment?
Yeah. So let's run over that again quickly
then. So the first cluster IP I have,
I have matched the name with the deployment
that we want to expose and the selectors
also match up. This is the ideal approach.
Right? Generally, this everything lines up, everything's the
same, if anything differs you can spot it
right away from the YAML, you understand what's
going on. Something else that's important to note
from all of these definitions that I've only
ever configured port
and the only port that is important is
the one in the container that I want
to expose over the service. You can get
away nine times out of 10 without ever
tweaking that and you'll be okay.
The next one we have is the node
info service,
so the selector is the same and that
I want this deployment, oops, excuse me.
I still want to target this deployment, but
I'm exposing a different port numbers. I've just
named the service to be slightly different.
Okay here, but obviously looking at it as
first glance, I'd go, oh, something's a little
different about this.
And then finally the note, sorry, and you
go Philip.
Could you expose both of them in the
same service?
Which is tricky. You can expose multiple ports
in the same service. Yes.
I guess And in this case, we could
because they're inside the same pod.
Right? So if you look at the first
one, we could have both of them exposed
there.
And because they're in the same pod, this
works. But if they were in the different
pods,
then the selectors would be different and then
we couldn't do this. Then we would need
to use two services.
Yes, you're correct.
And right, yeah, we should show that as
well.
Okay.
And then the last one is a node
port.
So we have a special name for that,
we're using the same selector, and again, we're
just targeting the one that we want to
expose. So this node port is the exact
same only instead of a cluster IP, it's
gonna, well you'll still get a cluster IP
I think, but it's gonna also expose a
high port number
that is available in any node within your
cluster and it will use the cube proxy
to route that to a port regardless of
the node it is on. And we won't
see that working, but we can try and
explain it just because that's a local cluster,
there is only one node. Okay,
so
let me reapply this so we get the
changes.
Oh yeah.
When you expose multiple ports like this, you
do need to provide a name to give
it some form of uniqueness.
Do you need in that case both if
they have different labels, both labels or how
how would it know
which one to
So when you call the service IP, you
can specify a port number and I believe
it will route you to the right one.
We'll confirm that actually. I think I've maybe
maybe just confused myself there.
Okay.
So let's take a look at our service
definitions. So we have our first one which
is here.
So annex one cluster IP, we have an
IP address and we can see that two
ports are available and we can query either
one. So we can query on port 80
default and get the NGINX service, we can
hit 8,080 and we'll get the node info
service.
We have our node info one, which is
the same as the first one, but
separate definition.
And then we have our node port one
here, so you can see we still get
cluster IP, so we can still reference it
within the cluster,
but we can also see here with this
colon that we have this high port number
of 30,202,
which actually means I can query from outside
of the cluster on any node IP on
that port number and it will route me
to one of the pods in that service.
Can you try it out?
Yes. I can. I was gonna say that's
a lot of work. Let's just actually finally
show it working. And I I know there's
lots of comments coming in. Let me get
back to that in a second once we've
actually shown something here. So
let's jump inside
one of these pods.
Let's get pods exec and two NGINX two
because we haven't exposed us at all yet
and
hopefully I've got bash.
Yeah, okay. Do I have curl? Yes.
So we're we could use the cluster IPs
for all of this, but one of the
nice things about Kubernetes is that we DNS
based discovery, which means we can actually use
a service name, but then the namespace with
very little configuration.
So what that means is I can just
query and it is one,
and you'll see I get the nginx response.
I can also change the port
and I get the node info response.
Okay.
Now I wanna change one more thing here
to show the load balancing as well. So
I'm gonna modify the replicas
on this deployment here.
Let's just run four
and then we'll go back in here. So
we can have that on Port 80 as
many times as we want and we get
NGINX. We can head it as many times
as we want on Port 8080.
And you'll see
the last part of the tuple, the naming
convention here is the pod ID and then
you can see we had load balanced across
two different pods there, when we requested that
service name.
Does that make sense? We understand what's going
on there. Okay.
The one question was also about port and
target port. Maybe we should talk about this
also a little bit.
Yes.
Let's
let me demo the node port then we'll
we'll tackle the target port as well then.
Okay.
And we're gonna do
so
let's try and get nodes, wait I get
an IP address. Yes. Okay, so this is
my
IP address of my node,
I think
Docker for Mac is going to let me
query that, we're about to find out and
I'm gonna target on 30202,
which is that node port, so this is
me outside of the cluster, this is me
on my local machine.
Of course that doesn't work, that was saying,
docker for Mac does provide a DNS name.
I have no idea if that's the right
one.
Should I use Linux?
Anyone know how Docker for Mac works?
Is there a way to SSH into the
virtual machine that it starts? No, you cannot
SSH into the virtual machine. There is a
DNS name though,
let me, let's just use the docs, right?
I mean, don't know everything, I Google stuff
more than I actually know stuff, so Docker
for Mac DNS name node port. Let's see
what the internet says.
Well, I also don't know any of this,
I have KubeCuttle explain all the time in
the background here. Yeah, exactly.
There is a DNS name
for Docker for Mac that allows you to
Docker for Mac dot local host.
Maybe I was close.
Docker from Mac did actually resolve and the
Docker from Mac.
Okay, let's try that IP address.
I don't think the node port works then
with Docker for Mac, so I can't show
you that.
And I don't know if I have any
clusters available. However, that would work, trust me.
Right? I'm a very trustable person.
The node port just means this,
I think what happens is the
CNI implementation or cube proxy whatever one it
is configures an IP table on all of
the nodes that says listening on this port
number, the 30202
and when the request comes in, it will
forward it to some pod on your cluster
somewhere.
Unfortunately, don't think I can show you it
working.
Which leads us on to Philips
thing now.
Target ports.
You wanna
what one would you like to change, Philip?
Well, I think we should actually change the
second one because
we have
the second one we listen on eighty eighty
in the actual process, right? Yeah. Which is
beneficial because we would rather want to have
all our ports listen on high level ports
because it doesn't require root or fancy capability
magic, right?
There's like a whole discussion if
unprivileged processes should be able to require low
level ports. But by default, on Linux, they
cannot. So anything that's not root, started by
root,
cannot
bind to any port that's below ten twenty
four, if I'm not mistaken.
And so we would need to run our
web server as root in order to bind
to port 80, which is usually not
encouraged. It's actually discouraged. I think that's the
word.
The benefit here is that we can use
a service
and have the services port be 80 but
have the target port be 8,080.
And this way, we can still talk to
our process by talking to some IP on
port 80.
But in the background, it's actually running under
and listening on port 8,080
and can be run as an unprivileged user
then.
Yes.
Let me try and Okay. Surmise that in
one lane then.
The reason we would use target port is
when we want our service to be available
on more traditional or privileged port numbers,
like we probably always want our web services
available on four forty three or 80. However,
the container port or the pod doesn't expose
the service on that port. The chances are
your pod is gonna be using something higher
like eighty eighty or 3,000 or 4,000 or
3,006
etcetera.
And instead,
what we do is we say, make our
service available on 80, however the pod is
going to be listening
on 8,080.
Now we can now reapply this,
and if we exec back into this pod,
we can do curl
and the service name here was, I know
it's node info.
We had on port 80, you know, so
it's just a default web port.
It's been forwarded to the pod on port
8,080 using the target port definition and then
gives us our response.
That's when you would choose target port is
when you wanna do a little bit of
juggling to get privileged port numbers available on
the service that aren't available on your pod.
Okay. In that case, the target port has
to match the
pod port.
Yes. And then that's when container port comes
in and you can juggle things even more
if you really, really, really want to. So
I think you mentioned this at the start.
Yeah. When you're configuring your ports here is
that you can actually expose this.
I think it's just port, is my auto
complete wrong or am I wrong?
Okay.
Maybe it is supposed to port.
Correct me, Philip. What have I got wrong
there? I thought you could specify container port
and expose it as a different port here,
but maybe I'm completely wrong.
I I think the most useful part of
this is you can name them and then
address them with the name.
You don't have to name
here. Say name something, web for example. Then
when you reference it from somewhere else, you
can reference it as the name.
Yeah. That's a good point as well, actually.
So you can see What is the benefit
of that?
You don't have to remember the port number
that you possibly.
Yeah. So here It refers the same. Right?
It refers yeah. To the
name port number. If we add a name
wipe here and a name node info here,
that means on our service definition instead of
of referencing
this.
Can you put web there or is it
just named like that? No.
I thought you could name it.
No. Here you can. Oh, no. No. That's
yeah. I'm I'm sorry. I'm being really silly.
Yeah. This is the pod. This is the
port we expose it on and then the
name is the one that is looking
up.
Well, I think what you can do here
with the name is
Kubernetes will set environment variables automatically
inside the process's runtime environment
that expose certain information about
service discovery. The two ways how you can
use Kubernetes service discovery is DNS
and those environment variables.
And based on these names, it will have
these environment variables that tell you how to
find that thing.
But you it will be something like I
don't don't you know, don't quote me on
this, but it's something like There. Oh, yeah.
You can see them there. Right? So it's
a service name port four four three, And
if you give them a name, they will
probably show up there
with that name also.
All right. We had a comment from Noel
who said try NodePort on localhost.
Just
why not?
Docker for Mac makes it easier than even
I thought it was supposed to be. So
you can see Docker for Mac does actually
handle the node port on my local networking.
So there you go. Node port does work.
Thank you, Noel.
Okay. Let's see. Do we get any I
think this is a very special case because
that's like, you know, there's networking magic many
many times now at this point already when
you do this on Mac and on local
host.
What's I think what's important to remember is
this. If you have actual for example, you
start cloud VMs and you were to start
Kubernetes by hand using kubeadm,
that those VMs would probably have an IP
address
and minus
security groups or something like this from the
cloud provider,
you could talk to those IP addresses.
Right? And if you say
node port, some port, you can talk to
this IP address
under this port from outside the cluster, and
the traffic will end up in your container.
Right? Because now that you can do localhost
and this port is just another layer of
networking magic
to somehow go from his local networking stack
on the Mac into this Linux virtual machine
and then inside there
eventually to the container.
Yes.
Lots of magic going on,
with Docker for Mac.
Alright. So we're kind of
approaching the the end of the time that
I have available at least here. So I
I wanna just check back and make sure
we actually explained more things than than raising
more questions. I hope that services are a
little bit more comprehendible now and if if
you have any final questions, let's try and
tackle them.
I think that was great.
Like,
more of a
hands on example than what you would get
the documentation where it's kind of explained from
one perspective
on what the different components are. Are there
any questions from the comments maybe
that or anything?
So we do have a few comments and
not particularly questions, just mostly people telling me
that I'm wrong, which I love.
So, Kustis says thank you for host port,
you don't know about that, he's gonna look
it up. We also have another comment from
Kustis who says that developers should or would
use ingress or load balancer services most of
the time. Yeah, you're right, I mean I
would discourage node ports as much as possible.
They're a temporary solution
for clusters that don't have a proper ingress
route yet.
But they are they're hacking and
balancer.
Load balancer is an edge case also. It's
it's a leftover from previous days. Yes.
Ingress is the new way, and it should
always be the default. You set this, and
I totally agree with this.
And the default for services should be cluster
IP. You should use services by default
to expose
a number of pods together within your cluster
so you can talk to them more easily.
You can find them and you can talk
to them with a load balancing.
If you want to expose outside of the
cluster, the default should always be ingress.
And then if you have a very specific
use case,
there are some other more technical things that
you then can look into like load balancer,
like node port, host port, all those
other things.
Then we have another comment from Andreas, which
I'm gonna try
and shorten a little bit. But when I
complained that I didn't know why we had
to have the selector
different from the template specs, selectors or labels
within the deployment spec. Apparently that was, it
didn't used to be enforced. So now if
I were to try and apply that to
the customer and they were different, I would
complain.
But
that's just a legacy thing that's kind of
hung around unfortunately.
And to say another comment from Noah just
in remembrance in the past, So that's all
covered
and that's all our comments. I think we
are all good.
I'll just say thank you both joining me.
Thank you for your questions. Thank
you Philip for bringing all of that knowledge
and helping us And I hope we didn't
raise more questions than we answered.
It's great. Thank you. Alright. Have a great
day. Thank you again and I'll speak to
both soon. Have a nice day. Bye. Bye
bye.